Traduttore: Cecilia Ferilli
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Il titolo del mio talk dice:
'Science is not a democracy',
il processo scientifico
non è un processo democratico.
E immagino che molti di voi
staranno storcendo il naso,
perché noi consideriamo democrazia,
i processi democratici -
teniamo molto in considerazione
questo concetto di processo democratico.
Ma quando sono stato invitato,
ho deciso di parlare di questo argomento
perché ho avuto in prima persona
modo di discutere
del fatto che
'Science is not a democracy'.
Ma per presentare questo episodio,
devo introdurre brevemente la mia ricerca.
Io studio queste classi di molecole,
che sono gli inositoli pirofosfati;
e in particolare devo introdurre
un precursore di queste molecole:
quello che si chiama ip6.
L'ip6 è uno zucchero inositolo,
con 6 gruppi fosfato attaccati,
per cui il nome inositolo sei fosfato,
abbreviato ip6.
Questa molecola è presente
in tutte le nostre cellule,
ma è particolarmente
abbondante nelle piante.
Infatti viene anche chiamato
phytic acid, in inglese, o acido fitico.
Si accumula soprattutto nei semi;
è presente nei fagioli -
100 grammi di fagioli contengono
da 5 a 10 grammi di ip6.
Questo fa sì che l'ip6
sia un prodotto naturale,
che si estrae a bassissimo
costo dalle piante,
e queste caratteristiche hanno fatto sì
che l'industria, soprattutto statunitense,
venda l'ip6 come integratore alimentare.
Così iniziò a introdurre l'ip6
come una panacea,
una cura ideale per molte malattie.
Cura il diabete,
previene la formazione di calcoli renali,
abbassa il colesterolo,
riduce il rischio d'infarto
e naturalmente serve anche
a curare il cancro.
Premesso questo,
due anni fa ho avuto il piacere
di collaborare con Robin Irvine,
uno dei maggiori scienziati
nel mio campo di ricerca,
dell'università di Cambridge.
E insieme a Robin abbiamo sviluppato
un nuovo metodo per l'analisi dell'ip6.
E con questo metodo si è andati a vedere
se l'ip6 era presente nei fluidi umani:
nel nostro sangue e nelle nostre urine.
E abbiamo scoperto che l'ip6
è assente da questi fluidi umani.
Tutti gli scienziati,
alla fine della loro ricerca,
devono pubblicare i loro risultati
su una rivista scientifica.
E con Robin siamo riusciti
a pubblicare questo lavoro
su questa rivista scientifica.
E alla conclusione della nostra ricerca
concludiamo che,
dato che nel sangue l'ip6 non è presente,
l'effetto benefico dell'ip6,
dato per reale da questa industria,
non può essere manifestato
dato che l'ip6 non può essere trasportato
dal sangue all'organo bersaglio.
Quindi sconsigliamo l'uso dell'ip6
come supplemento alimentare.
Naturalmente, il giorno dopo
che questo lavoro era stato pubblicato,
abbiamo ricevuto decine e centinaia
di mail contrarie che ci accusavano,
e che erano contrarie
al nostro punto di vista.
Vi faccio vedere,
alcune di queste mail
erano piacevoli da leggere
perché erano praticamente ridicole,
come la seguente,
in cui questa persona diceva
che con 4 grammi di ip6 al giorno
aveva ottenuto
'100% of resolution of chronic
fungal infection of thumbnail'.
Praticamente l'ip6 curava
l'infezione dei funghi nei piedi.
Abbiamo anche avuto mail che dicevano
che l'ip6 aiutava a far crescere i capelli
quindi era una molecola miracolosa.
Altre e-mail erano un po'
più elaborate, come la seguente.
Naturalmente dice che l'ip6
cura anche le malattie
neurodegenerative, come l'Alzheimer;
ma voglio attirare la vostra attenzione
sulla frase evidenziata in giallo.
In questa frase,
l'autore di questa mail dice che
'the vast preponderance
of scientific report
is set against your opinion,
you are a distinct minority.'
Che tradotto in italiano, significa:
'La grande maggioranza
delle pubblicazioni scientifiche
è assolutamente contraria
alla vostra posizione.
Voi siete in netta minoranza.'
But science is not a democracy.
Un processo scientifico,
non è un processo democratico.
Un fatto scientifico non diventa verità
solo perché la maggior parte
delle persone dice che è vero.
L'unico arbitro di veridicità
è la qualità e la riproducibilità
dei dati sperimentali.
Quindi, anche se noi
siamo gli unici a dire
che l'ip6
non dà nessun effetto,
i nostri atti sperimentali
sono high reproducible.
E quindi, anche se siamo
i soli a dire una cosa,
noi siamo nel lato corretto
della discussione.
Adesso voglio farvi un altro esempio,
un esempio molto più importante dell'ip6.
Un esempio storico.
Torniamo indietro
di qualche centinaio d'anni,
all'epoca di Galileo Galilei,
e facciamo un democraticissimo referendum:
facciamo decidere al popolo
se la Terra gira intorno al Sole
o se il Sole gira intorno alla Terra.
All'epoca di Galileo, secondo voi,
dove sarebbe finita la croce?
Ci sarebbe stato un plebiscito:
tutti, tranne uno, avrebbero detto
che il Sole gira intorno alla Terra.
Ma l'unico arbitro di veridicità
adesso sappiamo essere stato
la qualità e la riproducibilità
dei dati sperimentali
sul movimento dei pianeti
generati da Galileo,
che chiaramente all'epoca
non era riuscito a modificare
l'opinione pubblica
e aveva rischiato la vita per le sue idee.
All'epoca la Chiesa
utilizzava i testi biblici
per guidare
l'opinione pubblica;
ma i testi biblici non sono riproducibili,
non si possono testare in laboratorio.
Oggi la Chiesa ha perso
il suo potere temporale,
ma ci sono altre lobby,
altre ideologie politiche o culturali
che utilizzano ciò che gli scienziati
chiamano "pseudoscienza."
La pseudoscienza è una scienza
che non è riproducibile sperimentalmente,
che tenta di modificare
l'opinione pubblica.
Ed io credo che l'unica differenza
tra scienza e pseudoscienza
sia l'approccio al concetto democratico.
La pseudoscienza,
al contrario della scienza,
cerca il consenso democratico,
ma non degli altri scienziati,
ma principalmente dell'opinione pubblica,
per modificare le leggi
e per avere delle ricadute,
principalmente per il loro
personale interesse economico.
Ci sono molti argomenti pseudoscientifici
che vengono discussi in giro per il mondo:
gli organismi geneticamente modificati,
l'effetto serra, il link
tra l'autismo e le vaccinazioni.
Ma torniamo a casa nostra.
Ci sono state due discussioni
pseudoscientifiche negli ultimi decenni,
che per un ricercatore
che lavora all'estero,
per un italiano che lavora all'estero,
hanno fatto in un certo senso vergognare
del dibattito che hanno creato in Italia.
Queste discussioni pseudoscientifiche
hanno avuto risonanza internazionale,
quindi se ne è parlato molto all'estero.
E parlo del metodo Di Bella
e del protocollo Stamina.
E in tutti e due i casi - il metodo
Di Bella fino alla fine degli anni '90 -
si è bypassato,
si è andato oltre gli scienziati,
non si è creduto agli scienziati
che dichiaravano apertamente
la loro negatività
sul metodo Di Bella.
E si è cercato di modificare
l'opinione pubblica
per indurre lo Stato
a sovvenzionare una ricerca
che è stata fatta
spendendo milioni di euro,
e che ha dato risultati negativi.
Forse è per questo,
forse questa esperienza
ha permesso ai politici attuali
di bloccare il protocollo Stamina
che, vi posso dire,
era basato sull'acqua fresca.
Però il processo mediatico
che si era creato nei due anni precedenti
era quasi riuscito a modificare
l'opinione pubblica italiana
e a fare quasi investire
diversi milioni di euro
su un protocollo che non aveva passato
nessuna evidenza scientifica.
Per cui voglio concludere dicendo:
non abbiate paura degli scienziati.
La forma mentis di uno scienziato
è una forma mentis oggettiva,
non soggettiva.
Il metodo scientifico,
l'analisi oggettiva dei dati,
la loro veridicità,
la riproducibilità sperimentale,
sono princìpi che dovrebbero
essere applicati
non solo nei laboratori di ricerca,
ma in ogni aspetto della vita pubblica.
E anche se la scienza non è democratica,
la democrazia, il bene comune,
sono garantiti dalla scienza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)